now going for this pawn
and uh i would have thought this is
really not going to leave many more
chances okay this is a clever move
because now the white king will come in
and at least fort black force black's
king backwards at the right moment
though equally clever sets a nasty trap
if the white rook steps down two squares
and captures that black pawn black's
rook would have stepped up there would
have been a check and a skewer across
the board instead white steps forward
the king is checked back facts rook is
going to go away again and any anytime
the white king steps forward it gets
checked away that's the drawing
mechanism there
and it's so
so instructive how prag doesn't go
passive with his rook and get greedy
capturing pawns and allowing the white
king to reach the
the sixth row and instead every time the
king goes to the fifth row gets checked
away
and that's it
draw
a dramatic game that ends up in a draw
they are tied after the first game and
this intense fight